le Conseil Général de la Réunion vous
présente lien social le Conseil général
au côté des
Réunionnais sport extrême activité
culturell détente découverte ou tout
simplement loisir difficile d'en
profiter quand on est porteur de
handicap que ce soit pour des raisons de
coût ou
d'accessibilité avoir un handicap rend
les choses toujours plus compliqué alors
comment profiter des activités de
même quand on est porteur de handicap on
en parle maintenant dans lien
social c'est à saintleu que Monsieur
Bourdeu exerce en tant que moniteur de
parapante depuis maintenant 10 ans
amoureux de ce qu'il fait il a monté sa
structure pour pouvoir partager au mieux
sa passion avec le grand
public pour lui c'est un vrai plaisir de
procurer des sensations fortes à toutes
les personnes qui le souhaite monsieur
bourde accueille des clients de tous les
âges il a même récemment fait voler une
dame de 81 ans depuis l'ouverture de son
activité monsieur bourde reçoit aussi
des personnes handicapées mais le
pourcentage de ce public est encore très
faible le Conseil général a donc créé le
Pass loisir pour en bénéficier il suffit
de faire une demande de dossier une fois
le dossier traité les personnes qui
rentrent dans les critères reçoivent un
chquier d'une valeur de 270 € avec
lesquels ils pourront payer certains de
leurs
loisirs après avoir pris connaissance de
l'existence du Pass loisir monsieur
Bourdeau n'a pas hésité à faire en sorte
d'être partenaire de ce dispositif mis
en place par le Conseil général il y a 3
ans il y a un cadre fédéral spécialisé
justement dans le vol pour les personnes
à mobilité réduite est venu et a formé
plus d'une quinzaine de moniteurs qui
ont eu cette unité de formation et qui
sont maintenant capables d'encadrer et
il sont capables d'emmener une personne
et savoir faire un décollage et un
pososé avec un fauteuil roulant adapté
effectivement actuellement certainement
il y a un manque de communication de
notre profession où les gens sont
peut-être tout simplement pas au courant
mais la Ligue a acheté et mis à
disposition avec des partenaires
financiers deux fauteuils roulants hein
qui sont spécialement adaptés à la
pratique du vol libre c'est du matériel
qui vaut cher et qui à disposition pour
toutes les structures et tous les
moniteurs diplômés ça reste quand même
une clientèle qui est marginale euh
parce que simplement je pense c'est un
manque de communication pour avoir volé
avec euh beaucoup de personnes de tout
handicap de petit handicap à des très
gros handicap euh ça reste quand même un
moment pour pour cette clientèle qui est
extraordinaire puisque pendant que dure
le vol euh voilà on est loin du handicap
et voilà on c'est que du bonheur et
effectivement maintenant depuis que on
fait partie de ce réseau ça reste encore
marginal dans la globalité de notre
notre activité mais on commence à avoir
de plus en plus de demandes et de
personnes qui viennent et par le BIA des
associations aussi qui savent comment
fonctionne le
passeloisir voilà on commence à sortir
relativement souvent on va dire les
fauteuils et à faire voler ce public
handicapé le Conseil général met un
point d'honneur à ce que tous les
Réunionnais puissent être intégrés au
mieux dans la société des bureaux ont
été créés et réservés pour ce service et
des agents du Département font le
nécessaire pour pour que les personnes à
mobilité réduite aient elles aussi la
possibilité de se faire plaisir que ce
soit dans les sports extrêmes ou dans
d'autres activités elles ont aussi le
droit au loisir ce qui nous satisfait
très souvent c'est de voir des des
prestataires qui ont vraiment envie de
faire avancer les choses ils ont envie
de de partager ce qu'ils font de
partager enfin d'offrir ce service à des
personnes handicapées et donc il se
donnne les moyens en de le faire
certains
vont améliorer aménager l'accessibilité
d'autres vont essayer de mieux
communiquer c'est vraiment pour faire
plaisir il y a effectivement cette part
d'augmentation du chiffre d'affaires qui
est aussi à ne pas négliger mais ce
n'est pas que ça qui est visé par par
ceux qui vont qui veulent offrir la
prestation dans le cadre notamment de du
parapente ou l'association
à est parti jusqu'à former des moniteurs
pour pouvoir accompagner des personnes
handicapées euh sur bah sur les sur les
vols donc ça veut vraiment dire que ça
va loin c'est c'est pas juste un service
comme ça lambda c'est quelque chose qui
demande bah une certaine réflexion une
certaine un certain engagement sur l'ULM
par exemple on a aussi des des des
personnes qui ont été formées pour
accompagner des personnes handicapées
parce que voilà il y a il y a la
possibilité de faire des activités au
sol il y a des possibilité de faire des
activités dans les airs et vraiment là
on voit que ben il y a ce souhait
d'aider les personnes de de partager
surtout sa passion je pense que ça doit
être ça le le moteur c'est qu'on a une
passion ce qui font des activités ont
des passions et ils veulent partager ces
passions là donc ils font en sorte de de
tout faire pour partager comme Monsieur
bourdeux beaucoup de prestataires font
le nécessaire pour que tout le monde
puisse partager avec eux leurs patients
les avantages financiers réels ne sont
donc pas la seule motivation mais il
contribuent à ce que les opérateurs
économiques coiffeur cabinet d'
esthétique hôtel spa prestataire
touristiqu et sportif soit de plus en
plus nombreux à devenir partenaire du
passloisir le Conseil général se bat
tous les jours pour que ces notions de
solidarité se transmettent de génération
en génération l'engouement des
prestataires pour le Pass loisir est une
preuve de plus que le savoir-faire
ensemble fait partie des valeurs de la
Réunion pour devenir prestataire agréé
ou bénéficiaire du Pass loisir un numéro
vert unique le
0800008
952 le Conseil Général de la Réunion
vous a présenter lien social le Conseil
général au côté des
Réunionnais